petit pour tous les maîtres en pls là je
suis chaud pichot 19h58 va commencer à
20h juste bien m'installer j'essaie de
j'espère que la souris va bien marcher
mais je suis hyper chaud je suis chaud
patate
je suis chaud patate pas comment ça se
passe et je peux dormir une petite
demi-heure et du cou et du coup je suis
prêt à tous les mettre en place
concrètement c'est le projet ce soir je
sais pas comment ça va se passer je suis
pas sûr si on va tomber chez je sais pas
comment mais bon il ya un projet c'est
de les mettre en paix alès après on
verra on verra comment ça se passe
citons comme bien ouvert ajouté ce qui
est bien ouvert dites-moi si la vidéo
marche
en tout cas je suis très très chaud les
tontons je suis très très très très
chaud ok en trois minutes on casse on
est un peu tombé mais qu'est-ce que je
joue un peu en dilettante remontera à
2005 quand il faudra quand on aura
besoin des championnats il fait des
challenges à ces idiots avec fabien en
fait de mémoire je n'avais plus
exactement c'est un moment que j'ai
public sait mais ce n'est pas l'objectif
l'objectif c'est de bullet les flûtistes
un max de pls à lille va être 20 heures
le truc marshall et c'est parti alors on
à 26,23 on a un gros classement war on
doit elle subit un gros classement en
plus j'ai pas su pas sûr qu'on va que
c'était 2007 mais sur un rush de malades
mais du coup 26-23 monstrueux comme
classement bullet et ou qui a déjà dit
je n'ai pas d'adversaire déjà à
tchatche.com cherche là ils ne peuvent
pas ils ne peuvent pas ils sont là et
comment on lui trouve un adversaire déjà
le site est en pls de base
venez je vous attends je vous attends
tous on attend on fait une recherche ont
envahi par un challenge à tout le monde
et ils sont déjà rien que pour accepter
le challenge sont des gens pls vous vous
êtes c'est qui ces types
où ils sont oui son ouais ils ne veulent
pas accepter
ils ne veulent pas accepter la junte et
j'ai lutté je montre je vais boire du
thé je me demande toujours comment tu
peux être aussi chaud mais en fait c'est
parce que le mode 8000 colons thiam
mille colombes ça te ça chauffe
non c'est un état naturel en fait je
suis toujours super chaud comme dirait
femmes en écoutant super heureux tout en
super heureux tout donc je suis super
heureux mais toujours en tous sens super
heureux allez venez qu'est ce qu'ils
font ils ont peur ils font dans leur
caleçon vous tremblez déjà et accepter
mes défis je lance des défis de partout
où je suis là je suis tout le temps je
suis partout où ils sont ils sont nuls
parviennent ne peux pas te veut pas
offrir enfin qui demande quand est-ce
qu'on revoie vla normalement on va
revoir vlad pour le retour de gary boom
le retour de gary le retour de vlad
plane le patron qui en chine qui
accompagne reach ou qui est partout tout
le temps partout vlad bon jeu offre trop
de défis là dessus ce point comme sont
pas contents vous n'avez pas le droit
d'offrir plus de cinq défis bail mais
bon que qu'est-ce que je fais défi
personnel
je ne comprends pas les jeux refresh
ouais mais bon on va dire si personne
n'a que 7 mai 10 fiches d'objet de
défier plus de gens enfin je ne sais pas
je n'ai pas le choix
non mais devenu qu'enfin je suis là quoi
je vais vous mettre en plein boom sergei
cigale co vient justement psg pas de
mettre en place son ballon et c'est pas
grave
venez tous importe qui mais je sais pas
a faim je ne sais pas là je suis
beaucoup trop chaud pour que personne
accepte mais challenge en fait c'est pas
possible je suis en train de bouillir
que je suis dont je suis dans le peloton
j'ai besoin de m'échapper quoi je ne
peux pas rester au milieu de tous ces
coureurs
je vais un peu comme de genk quoi je
parle tous les jours mais je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas que se passe-t-il est
acceptée verso accepte la ccl moi qui
suis en pls là du coup
demain c'est eux qui devait tremper à
l'aise c'est là et l'a tellement ils
sont tous entamant ils n'en peuvent plus
on on n'en peut plus d'attendre et allez
on va essayer en ninja paraguay ninja
qu'aimer juge je propose vraiment à
beaucoup de genres de jouer enfin je ne
comprends pas où êtes vous où sont ils
voilà voilà c'est pas grand ninja je le
sentais bout des garages g4 dans ta
gueule hkd bien bouger 6 mangent les
pions boom prendre un deuxième
vas-y dégage mouche vincent pion
bessette où le cavalier qui surgit de la
nuit
bush de prends ça des cadres dont je les
pions s'en fout des garages alors
d'apprendre ça le 3 folie id food et 5
qu'est ce que fait ma souris m'a souri
ma souris me joue des tours
je sens pas du tout ma souris ce soir
mais allez on va pas se déconcentrer
tu me donnes un pion je te le promets
mots qu'est ce qui fait aller grand
roque c'est dans l'esprit tourner si
c'est dans l'esprit à fond il va faire
tour à cette france et 6 et la dame qui
repart c'est le beau jeu où mon menace
tu as tout rond vaste où partout tout le
temps
boum échec va rentrer dans une finale
ah mince j'avais envie de allez on va me
faire ça intermédiaire aller les coûts
intermédiaires c'est le beau jeu allait
le beau jeu boum pour projet 7 dans ta
gueule à moi j'ai pas fou prend 1,6
c'est de la merde c'est de la merde
liquide théorie puis complètement
perdant tu complètement foutu bon allez
on va prendre ça on va bientôt aborder
cette partie c'est pas grave à revenir
ok il a gagné une bataille il n'a pas
gagné la guerre arrive à dire on va
quand même tenté on va tenter le beau
jeu le beau j'ai tout le temps à fond on
n'a plus rien
c'est de la merde a tenté le beau jeu ça
va pas marcher à ok on a quand même des
menaces des soldes boom des 5 où vas tu
as tout résident des garages suite à
pied avec madame je vais partout
à
ok on a perdu c'est palace pas été bien
remonté à l'est revient ouais ok mais
s'il accepte pas la revanche c'est qu'il
en pls quelque part j'ai un peu trop
avec ma sourire j'ai un peu de mal mais
ok qu'est ce que c'est ça une partie le
mec se barre bon ok ce don qu'il en pls
en gros parce que si les parents perez y
rejoue boon estero ce qui dégage dégage
avec thé qui est à main je les faire ces
4 h croire avoue c'est de la merde
boum boum et qui a injecté pièces
allaient boom la dame qui vient le
développement de partout l'activité ou
g5 c'était une feinte
avec la crise il faut être quatre une
idée c'est complètement de reculer que
le fou de partout tout le temps son
souffle et 3 c'est pas grave
uj rock quatre tirages
ça crée un sacre un loup je te prends
ton pions ils font en bessac attend pls
de partout tout re 1
on est là on est partout on sait feu de
tout bois boom le bois de partout un
recul avec des pièces dégage foodie bout
mais si je te prends kaïs et 6
on va te mater a laissé des pions c'est
de la merde ça sert à rien
et on se défend on est pas mal
prince qu'on a plus de temps bush de
clous des garages des gages cagettes et
pièces belle finale et gagnante 1 ces
grands mecs ça c'est un grand maître
c'est qui ce type
maintenant on a plus de temps
malheureusement donc on va devoir
prendre la nulle dégage boum c'est de la
merde les pions on prend le vase y mange
bien je rate ma tempe et à l'est un peu
plus
ok ça veut rentrer dans des finales
salage ou petits caleçon n'importe quoi
elle voyait ça c'est n'importe quoi le
mec toile à ces finales pour final
tellement ça m'énerve lui enlever madame
en fait à main s'il apprend direct c'est
pas possible c'est pas le beau jeu ça
c'est pas le beau jeu
allez vas-y vient d'attaquer partout
tout le temps cavalli qui viennent tous
halal damois la vase il dégage des cas
les clients b 5 c positionnelle boum
c'est les échecs positionnelle regarde
le coût de la conception du jeu b5 dans
ta gueule
ok je te prends des gages tourbe et je
dégage aussi je dégage partout tout le
temps roi des scènes je protège tous
merdasse eu mal mais c'est pas grave
massacre à g et on se bat quand même on
va à fond ou je te crie partout des
clous et en peux plus t'en peux plus tu
es cloud est partout qui n'existe plus
me fous tignyemb et 4 allée leroy qui se
bat les batwa leroy boom dégage on
défend tous ou pas revient le retour on
attaque tout mince et a pu reprendre et
c'est beau jeu c'est le beau jeu de
boules dégagé 4 boum boum mince je vais
faire c'est 4 c'est quoi cette souris de
merde c'est le beau jeu c'est le beau
jeu la souris nous aide pour faire le
beau jeu boum f4 bien je t'attends tu
est menacée de toutes parts c'est très
très chaud là il ya des trous de partout
boum une pièce en d'un couvent asie
pourrait vous protège des pièces où il
voit plus les pièces y voit plus rien
c'est une forêt noire comme lire et
comme dirait talent tu ne vois plus rien
tu n'en peut plus
goom je reviens en défense or dans ta
gueule
si vous n'en a plus de temps c'est chaud
truc s'il ya des pièces de partout des
fourchettes masson se mater quelle
horreur y at il un peu trop fort mais
bon boum dégagent à mains c'est
théorique boom gwangju les nouveautés
bout la nouveauté dans va le jouer les
nouveautés dans le benko avec le pion
qui arrive en g4 et boum les garages
dont la nouveauté dans le paint qu à
cette souris de l'histoire q vous vous
foutez dans le benko de partout à
l'hérésie mangement jah ainsi l'a vu
jouer le piéger
à l'égout c'est chaud c'est le bordel
les mecs guidage chèque
et on est bien on est bien mais pas mal
dans cette partie on fait le beau jeu en
plus garage dégage
nous petits rois que le coup tranquille
mbk jam est toujours à b4 il se défend
il est robuste
doit-on la paix robuste au là c'est
relou avec son cavalier
nous
vas-y protège ta tour sourit de merde
dégage dégage vas-y revient bout j'ai
vraiment du mal avec ma souris et chant
ps bout on se bat fond
à
allez on se bat h théâtre c'est dans
l'esprit boom
ok tu échanges et les pièges et tu veux
jouer à ça pas avec nous comptons moon
bay 4 c'est dans l'esprit tomber un an
protège mes cinq cavaliers c6 dans ta
gueule c'est de la merde mais commençait
fort comment sais tu mens pls même pas
il le prend il fait dans son caleçon
n'aimes pas tu le prends ce cavalier
foot a même pas le courage de le prendre
les booms h5 on attaque de partout
ok ils verront très matinal ils veulent
jouer koné finale
oh
cette souris on essaiera tant ces deux
bons il a raté en attendant allez faut
se battre
à
il n'en peut plus il en peut plus
on est un peu trop lent on a un peu trop
lent m'ont fait le beau jeu allez on va
être juste cette variante du benkova
très connu la vente du benko tu
sacrifies tout ouïe veut plus prendre de
pions prend les je te dis il a peur vous
avez il prend plus aucune pièce il prend
plus rien il n'en peut plus on en en
train de
on est complètement en train de le
mettre en pls je peux vous dire que ce
mec là à la fin du à la fin des beats il
ne sait plus jouer aux échecs
on est en train de lui détruire le
cerveau là le mec n'a plus de cerveau il
ne s'est absolument plus jouer au jeu
d'échecs en fait c'est un jeu il ne
connaît à peine les règles en fait il
n'en peut plus en fait je peux vous le
dire enfin je me sens chanceux de jouer
contre lui ce qui en vain de se passer
pour lui c'est horrible c'est ces
deux-là perez de niveau 50
il est incapable de jouer aux échecs
c'est d'enfermer madame amincie l'enfer
madame verrai ça va déjà fou j'ai poussé
5 ça va je tiens mais je peux vous dire
qu'il est dans le dur là
je vous assure qu'il est dans le dur de
chez dur il n'en peut plus je pense que
vous faites confiance vous vous le
sentez vous aussi il est grand maître je
sais pas combien il est on vous
regardera qui ça après je veux dire que
là il ne sait plus jouer aux échecs moi
c'est impressionnant c'est pls de niveau
50 là le mec mais aussi super conclu non
mais je reviens ici
erwan et six au prochain dégage avec ta
cour c'est fantastique
le mec ne sait plus jouer aux échecs
c'est fini génial c'est génial
un avocat il peut me faire tomber il
peut gagner ce tube il sait plus jouer
aux échecs on lui a détruit le cerveau
en fait c'est génial franchement ça me
fait plaise
nous maths en un dégage
il est il et il est laid l'on peut plus
c'est fantastique
gk juste cinq buts en train d'exploser
tu es en train d'exploser
le score de ce match n'a plus aucune
importance honte à détruire cerveau
autant peu plus ramassée à la civière il
va finir sur une civière ce joueur il
est fini il pas peut-être prendre sa
retraite après cette partie
il n'en peut plus bon on s'en fout des
fous ça sert à rien à ses débuts aux
échecs ça ils changent les dames annie
rond dans la finale à merde la finale
est pas top
camaïeu ça un gouffre otages manquions
je t'emmerde
je protège tout il veut se rassurer avec
des finales nous les petites tactiques
n'en peut plus olalala l'eau comme en
mai août et nesterov
nesterov skiff j'espère que j'espère
qu'il sait où j'habite à 1 parce que
sinon on le retrouve plus là c'est fini
dit déjà faire échec c'est de la merde
bafouée cinq objets de sacrifier bouffe
wef six échecs et dégage a été pièces de
mer jonas m'attend de tu dis garage
boudent abandonne temps peu plus et il
reprends toi des nouveautés théorique
dans la gueule vas-y tu sais plus je
faisais juste 5 quand même je t'emmerde
bien jouer aux échecs sa livrée échec ça
à tonton gf cinq phases îles vierges ou
vrai échec avec nous tu as démolissent
cerveau tonton temps peut plus laisser
des pions je t'ai expliqué ça sert à
rien combien de fois il va falloir te
l'expliquer c'est horrible se rend pas
compte quand c'est de la merde
vous vous positionnez et des singes avec
mes pires des cas
dépôt mensuel vous positionnez en caisse
et ont tué trois de merde
le garage des cages faut que je te
menace je vais te tuer et rasé c'est
chaud là n'était pas très bien mais
c'est pas grave allait boum on se bat un
peu chaud
et vous me prends ça ici
là où tadaaam tonton tu as dame aux
raisons de tatouage carte mais qu est ce
que tu as de la chance je pousse mon
pions je garde mon ressenti et les
concepts des échecs c'est les échecs
vrai ça garder son roi au centre tonton
c'est vrai échec ça non la thur tombe
dans les travers tout matériel arrête il
retombe dans ses travers
où je t'échange blida ben tout ce que tu
sais faire c'est faire tomber les gens
en fait cette crise jouant la pendule en
fait
à
ok été obligé de jouer comme ça ok bravo
bravo ok je note
je note sinon tu existes plus n'existe
pas de toit sont existe de plus c'est
fini tu es complètement dans notre idée
complètement rentré dans notre matrice
en fait t'es rentré dans la matrice tu
sais c'est fini on ne te reverra plus
mince et là je perds une pièce en un
coup c'est comme oscar iode de toute
façon c'est déjà fini pour toi fini pour
toi objet est obligé de jouer autant que
jésus a répondu quand on parle de vrais
échecs il ya plus personne mais
l'évasion val mater avec deux pièces de
moi ben ça fou pour acter les pandas
mans au caire à tessala allez vas-y
revient
mais dégage g5 c'est les coups ça c'est
les échecs
j'ai 4 ans pousse ses pions partout bien
un petit coup de petit coup de mou là
c'est mauvais ça surprend b5 on mange un
pion d'un coup grosse erreur très très
mal joué on tombe dans le piège prendre
des pions les fausses échec nous la dame
en h4
voilà les coûts qui nous plaisent
alors maintenant
et on va faire ça on va les protéger
notre truc on est assez mal quand même
et c'est pas grave
donc si on a plus de temps très très mal
joué de ma part cette partie c'est de la
merde allez vous mon futur tous les
côtés d'échiquier on est partout
je joue une finale pas du tout dans
l'esprit
à
allez-vous on se défend
ce qu'adam h 6 allez on va faire dame
proches de nan on n'y arrive pas c'est
pas grave
un échec va venir tout défendre ben ok
on him as tu souffres un petit peu on
souffre un petit peu loose g45 h4 on est
dans le dur on est dans le dur je vais
faire damas quatre plutôt conviendront
convient il faut qu'on revienne
on pioche là on pioche sakai b4 high
tech arrivons détroit c'est horrible on
se fait marcher dessus on se fait
marcher dessus
il faut qu'on revienne faut qu'on
revienne
ouvrant le pion bout montants donnent un
deuxième dégage nouveau le jeu on fait
le buzz on va dégager ce cavalier
on s'en fout ça ne sert à rien tu as un
pion qui a avancé à larrau s'en fiche a
les boules on donne encore un pion
c'est dur là pour nous c'est très dur on
est très très mal
pioche un petit peu
et vous mesdames et de maths
là on a du mal on a du mal les gens nous
arrive une ouverture ne veut plus rien
c'est fini les mecs des plus en pls
il était bien enterré simplement et là
il a réussi à se refaire une deuxième
basque puisque est-ce que voilà est-ce
qu'il n'ya pas eu à un moment donné un
protocole commotion il n'aurait pas dû
revenir sur le terrain ceux ci la
question que je me pose pas ce qu'elle
est vraiment le droit de continuer à
jouer ou pas on ne sait pas aller boom
allez on y va on attaque de partout tout
le temps
gueye c4
où on défend tous c'est pas grave ça que
c'est important à menacer tf6 échec
c'est horrible
on est complètement inexistant et on se
barre avec le roi c'est pas grave
ou mal et on joue tout pour le tout non
c'est eric est un piège à ya encore un
échec non quelle horreur non on n'a rien
on n'a rien on n'a même pas un échec on
n'a rien n'en peux plus c'est fini
difficile difficile
on peut dire qu'on est en grosse
difficulté la manne d'ailleurs ça a été
un peu trop fort on va passer s'abattre
les deux dames 2
c'est que maintenant ils jouent très
solide en fait n'arrive plus du tout à
l'attaqué
c'est horrible si pour la qualité si
j'essaie de prendre du matos pas très
grave affaire tourbe et on va lui
laisser prendre ces dons à faire bref de
mai très heureux allez on a peut-être
une position qui se joue à massada prend
ici on attendait c'est le beau jeu c'est
le bol il y en a partout de tous les
goûts tous les coureurs sont disséminés
la sueur sur l'asphalté fait un échec
erich hess décennies et de partout
non c'est plus de temps
j'ai trouvé le bon coup mais j'ai plus
de temps quelle horreur n'était pas trop
mal dans la partie mais bon
à moi
bah ça devient difficile ça vient très
difficile maintenant devoir changer
d'adversaire il est trop fort
non a tenté le tout pour le tout pour
faire là pour faire pls maximum on
n'était pas loin quand même
on se bat bien on fait les coups les
plus bizarres du monde la fois f5
complètement loufoques comme coup c'est
génial sûrement très très mauvais d'un
bep cadre là on est partout fait feu de
tout bois
malheureusement ça marche année
on a fait vraiment fait de pouvoir tout
tenté
on aura fait le beau jeu à un moment
ça n'aura pas suffi je suis le plus
malheureux
thaïs et 6 malheureusement ok peut-être
que
à
ben ça marche pas du tout madame ces
chèques c'est fini
bon allez on tente une dernière sinon on
changera adversaire il trop et trop
puissant
alors essayé de jouer normalement pour
commencer j'ai pu très normal on va
essayer de ne plus faire j'ai quatre
essais jeu un poil plus sérieux c'est
toujours napper allait semer un peu
moins précise entre dès le début
[Musique]
la vraie paix à l'aise ses coup-francs
gc ca de toute façon les mecs va pas
commencer à boom dégage
non j'en fais trop j'en fais trop j'en
fais trop
ça passe pas ça passe pas du tout ça
passe pas du tout
à
ça ne passe pas du tout ça ne passe pas
du tout c'est de jouer jouer jouer
quelques coups sérieux au début on va
revenir on va revenir on va revenir il a
trop pris la confiance cela va nous
faire une radio zig boom et une rigueur
à gauche sinn revisité par la buzine
revisité tu vas voir ça voilà tu dis que
c'est une ragots zinn était très très
heureux
mais tu vas voir c'est très très
revisitée mais le font ici va mettre le
fou ici on va venir tôt mathématicien
non la souris
mais pas l'arabe usine de mathieu
cornette fait attention un autre type de
ragots zine ça
[Musique]
ok c'est pas grave il a de nouveau une
finale perdante
j'avais vraiment beaucoup trop confiant
cela
à
ben c'est ma tour tian prise assez
horrible hier matin
quelle horreur à quelle horreur on en
paie à l'est sont un peu plus on a fait
illusion on a fait illusion mais c'était
bien en début de match et puis après on
a complètement craqué
on va se battre à fond quand même vous
qu'on aille le maté à l'efo faut qu'on
organise une - c'est pas possible
beaucoup trop en confiance et on s'en
fiche on lui donne on lui donne pas il
vient prendre la qualité vient prendre
la tour on ça fou à les cayes ces 2
vient de battre pour y faire kg cas tf6
dans sa gueule vous mais il prend le
matos on s'en fout
c'est très petit caleçon tout ça
où ils panache ou et le panache aïe aïe
aïe d'ailleurs j'ai très mal joué après
mes bons ou une panache de l'adversaire
ou elbow jeu où est le plaisir
non je le beau jeu à fond à 200% on est
200 % johnny 400% johnny on est 1000%
johnny je suis johnny hallyday vous
géniale idée dégage boom la tour en e3
aller le beau jeu une nouvelle fois il
s'échappe
il rentre dans une finale assez sur le
même scénario mais on va tomber
notez il nous fait tomber quel dommage
oui bon je voulais faire des 4,5 à la
prochaine on s'en fout boom des gages
well well beau jeu
on se fait punir c'est punir parce qu'on
pêche à vouloir faire du beau jeu
alors faire de la pls
mais le romantisme aux échecs ça se perd
d'anjou dans l'esprit
on peut pas jouer plus dans l'esprit que
ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui ma famille est
très fière
damien très fiers de nous voir armes à
la main
très quand même c'est qu'on n'a plus
rien à
ton les armes à la main le problème
c'est qu'on tombe
beria ton prend ici on n'y arrive
vraiment pas à dire ça est bien trop
fort
n'arrivons pas à nous mettre en pls on
va continuer à se battre à fond
elle va faire dame bekkat échec à tout
moment
insupportable
un bon début
quand le final
on ne peut rien faire quand le beau jeu
tout le temps ça ne peut pas marcher
tels des jo va nous pouvons pas résisté
aux tristes cynisme de notre adversaire
allez boom il faut y croire
tout en a il nous manque un temps il
nous manque un temps pour réussir
quel dommage
quel dommage mais on va tenter ça n'a
pas un superbe début
jamais à jouer l'attaqué
on traverse harry change sans arrêt les
pièces
il faut dire que c'est bien fait
privilégions le résultat
talant from du cyclisme
oumma 5 dure loi du sport boules beau
jeu enfin matt des gages à les boums
enfin on en a placé 1 enfin le beau jeu
a triomphé c'est peut-être que le début
les gens je suis plus chaud que jamais
le beau jeu enfin revenu et reculons
mourront les armes à la main
mais il faut prendre et c'est peut-être
en faire un échec ici
enfin c'est complètement raté cet échec
très très mal joué nous perdons une
pièce une dame
ils ont perdu une dame
quelle horreur
quel dommage
nous étions bien battu
nous étions bien battu nous allons
repartir cette ouverture s'est montré
très efficace dans la partie précédente
boudin békaa dégage
nous mourrons les amarres les armes à la
main vous voyez nous rejouerons que
l'adversaire malgré les défaites qui
font que je dois vous l'avouer mal à la
tête mais nous nous ne nous ne plierons
pas tels des roseaux n'oublieront mais
nous ne romprons pas tels des roseaux
nous sommes des roseaux où les roseaux
dans ta gueule cavalier e 5 1 les boums
allez les roseaux on va prendre affaire
à six salles et la dame qui revient vous
mon prendre ça allait les gens salah
faut la prendre
foyer à gagner cette partie avec les
tripes alors montré ici qu'on a du coeur
ici on des causses
si on a des tripes
allez les gens
si vous jouez la pendule
à
dégage ok tu respecte rien tu
n'abandonne pas boum d'égal montre ici
qu'on a du coeur de montrer ici qu a des
tripes à lui montré ici comme des
cojones t il sans vapes
ça y est comme d'habitude quand ils
sentent qu'ils perdent le pied ils s'en
vont ce qu'on n'a pas du tout fait on a
on n'est pas parti on est resté malgré
tout on a un peu changé les ouvertures à
la fin ça a bien marché les bons il part
à ça nous laisse comme un goût amer
j'aurais dû jurer qu un peu changé mais
g4 g5 et rejoue un peu plus normale
c'était leur choix sera fait rappeler le
mois dans le chat les gens qu'en mai car
est d'être en paix à l'est contre la
drogue il faut il faut modifier les
ouvertures
c'est quelque chose on a un peu oublié à
léon jeu contre 1 belge ou dégage vous
boum boum on rentre de partout contre le
belge
allez tentons de 3 pour empêcher les
fouets fkt cheikh tranquille vient
tonton on va échanger tranquille
nous on est là on est de partout et
cavaliers allez les canassons de partout
regarde sa vie à venir regard up
il recule alors ça est sous pression car
ils sont là tout est là tout et partout
on apprend ici à venir prendre sur tempo
va regagner deux pions va prendre d'ici
sur échec on m'apprend d'ici on va
prendre ici blum dégage dégage bourhis
boom tu apprends des nouveautés dans les
scandinaves qui les a même jamais vu de
ta vie vous g5 dans la scandinave tu
dégages
bouton cavalli il est très très mal
placée à cause du boom boom h4 des cages
tranquille dégage avec tes pièces
comprend jean doublé c'est très très
bien très gros conseil stratégie doublé
ses pions c'est très très bien ça vous
êtes beaucoup maintenant tranquille on
protège le pion f6 très heureux de la
dépouille ont doublé et maintenant on va
les dégager de partout tout le temps
enfin combien son cavalier ses lettres
je ne sais pas ce que je fais mais je le
fais ok et je pouvais changer échanges
migrants rock dans ta gueule
carrez qui se replace en tilt fond de
court
blum échec re découverte
je reviens regard-là mariton qui
t'arrive dessus c'est le quinze de
france petit c'est le quinze de france
où le quinze de france
boum boum c'est le quinze de france dans
ta maison tonton ok on recule alors il
fallait aller sur une case un peu plus
lointaine c'est pas grave
blue du quinze de france et cheikh bou
dégage nous nous méfions qui t'arrive
dessus g6
comment je t'ai fait un trou j'étais
complètement affaibli tu es complètement
faible n'en peux plus t'en peux plus tu
dégages
ould hamma catch de menaces
loulou jeu les deux manches et on pions
c'est le bordel il n'en peut plus une
voix plus rien
kvh 4 je sauve mon option g6 le pion de
la grob valeur inestimable et qui a valu
à trois je protège tous partout harmonie
des pièces un cavalier à trois quarts
vide en h4 garde ses beaux apprend c'est
un tableau c'est de la peinture c'est
van gogh
regardons fou fou f1 je recule je te
prends ton fou et je repars avec madame
de l'autre côté home ainsi fait échec
c'est pas grave je pars à libé cinq
crans ici tranquille c'est le beau jeu
de partout b3 tranquille je développe
mes pièces stratégie long terme
tourache trois coups deux tours
latérales quand classics f3 je défends
tout tout est défendu tant peu plus des
je reviens fois trois jeux des jeux
voilà jeu
j'échange les pièces à congeler dameron
une finale complètement gagnante jeu
quatre aces 2 - je suis bien où je
pousse mes pions le pion passé le
concept du qui ont passé dans ta gueule
pourquoi j'ai plus de temps pourquoi je
n'ai plus de temps à l'est entre pays
nourrit qu'à une green votre jeu laverie
scandinave web ou mach iii pour empêcher
g5 ça sert à rien j'ai cinq quand même
c'est théorique tu dégages
théorie dans ta gueule dégage toutes les
théories petit rock joue complètement à
l'inversé de ce que tu penses tu peux
plus tu n'est plus que l'ombre de toi
même je n'ai plus tôt ton ta propre
ombre on peut plus
boum-boum ton tomates en à tonton tu
n'es qu'une ombre qui n'est qu'une ombre
tu n'en peut plus beau risque atteint
est ce que c'est on est locataire sont
91 c'est la question les shows partout
des quatre coups le double fiorito tente
le plus double enquête au fond ces
quatre gars t'es trou tu es casse
blanche de faire un échec pourrait
développer tranquille
il vient de prendre vient de prendre si
t'es un homme il a rejoué la smat en un
est dans le dur
et je te prends je te masta dame elle va
ou escalader case où sont les cases tu
recules et on continue à avancer on
avance
c'est chaud je vois plus rien caïds et
un quelques coups de fond de court
conception conception des échecs on
remonte
on peut plus il ya des pièces attaqué de
partout tout croche cinq arrivées les
deux bouts des deux tours attaquer si
cette fois ci sous crysis et g7 le pion
qui va à dame
on va chercher le pion avec le roi
notre adversaire on peut plus c'est sûr
malheureusement n'a plus de temps
dommage vous dire prends toi reprends
toi ou tu avec des cats ont peu plus
t'as plus d'ouverture tu ne sait plus
jouer
je ne sais plus jouer aux échecs c'est
fini
trop de paix à l'aise dans ce monde
qu'avec ton fous n'ont bougé 4 on a tous
les coups du tennis on et romain
complètement au dessus de toi boulou
match 5h 4h 3 dans ta gueule bout mon
sens où tu t'attaques notre fou c'est le
festival le son des chèques
c'est une leçon d'échec est vraiment en
train d'apprendre le placement de pièces
rouges et 5
le concept très important garde-t-on
ressentent quand le roi et sur l'aide
qu'ils attaquent les concepts 7
positionnelle quand on menace m'attend
demain tu protèges cdu taixing dégâts
avec ta pièce est maintenant se recentre
aucune menace ne passe rien ne rende un
f6 dégage abandonne abandonne c'est la
scandinave fg 5 dans ta gueule
une variante très très connue de tous
les spécialistes move la double robe ou
double grob regard commenté à crédit
partout le fou qui sort
dames c'est un tranquille tu perds
attend ait had any way serriérois f1
très bien protégé le cavaly qui arrivent
ici loup
c'est un peu chaud l'adhérent tu donnes
ta dam ça sert à quoi elle donnait
saddam tonton val et encaissé ton pions
tour g1 cavalière six échecs on va être
matée
alain prend des risques vous des risques
complètement inexpliquées mais parce
qu'on a envie de prendre des risques ce
que j'ai envie de mettre mon rang f4
allez c'est l'esprit cavaliers si c'est
de la merde mais c'est dans l'esprit a
il prend pas quel petit caleçon c'est
pas possible
comme chez prendre ces pièces j'ai 3
c'est pas dans l'esprit je si c'est dans
l'esprit à fond ça vous
à
et on a fait le beau jeu il a gagné
autant dégage mouture reprend j'ai 5 à 6
on s'en fout c'est si l'un des mythes
à
un concept d'action doublé l'entaillage
danse et je peux te faire d'options
doubler les injustes à poser aux autres
ça sert à rien mais c'est boulot les
pions losange ou le losange
il n'a jamais vu ça le cavaly client
développé sur le bord très très fort
vous confions le fameux concept carrillo
bord très fort car il au milieu ça pue
à
allez on se bat
va faire feu de tout bois
et c'est le beau jeu ma main samatan ne
s'est pas le beau jeu du budget 4
jusqu'à pour le momen encore dans ce
match aller faut continuer on protège
tous
c'est le beau jeu c'est le beau jeu
à
cavalier sur le bord absolument
n'importe quoi c'est génial c'est
fantastique ça n'a absolument aucun
rapport avec riant sont en train de
faire c'est fantastique c'est absolument
idiot
c'est génial
c'est une des parties les plus géniales
blum h c'est fantastique conception
positionnelle la dame qui va revenir en
c1 protège le fou il n'avait pas du tout
anticipé fouet fin je défends tous les
gros rock oms aux échecs comme dans un
rêve
on joue aux échecs comme dans un rêve
les gens on est tellement au dessus du
game on est tellement au dessus du game
il n'en peut plus on est trop au dessus
du game il ya le game qui elle est là et
nous on est là on est là on est au
dessus du game ou bien c'est trop dessus
du game ce coup
boom au dessus du game
pour le syntagme dégage on change de
fusil d épaule
vous
à 6b 5 trop dessus du game une nouvelle
fois boubée 7h 5h 4 c'est génial
oh non au nom métro au dessus du game on
a donné une dame qui ont continué à se
battre une dame serrières dans les vrais
échecs une dame sait rien faut le savoir
comment il ya un matin ici pour lui mais
bon c'est pas grave on va se battre à
fond tout le temps partout on est tout
le temps là tout en se défend on se bat
font partout tout le temps
enfin c'est un peu dur allez le roi qui
monte à les rodgeur rodgeur à rodger
federer un peu court et monte à la volée
c'est un peu court
ok on joue contre un idiot
ouais j'y fais attention à ce que tu
fais
[Musique]
ok il s'amusait c'est pas grave
bouh bouh vas-y bien
c'est vos amis ça c'est vos amis se
foutent de notre gueule
ces foutus de ma gueule la partie
précédente il va devoir le payer
tu vas payer pour cette foutu de notre
gueule cage paye unités puni par là où
taper chez mes expressions la nuit tu
dégages boris as tu as fait de mal avec
tes cinq dames est maintenant temps pls
quand tu vas te cacher vous boom tu as
voulu faire le malin ça se retourne
contre toi je suis un chat je t'emmerde
je te marche dessus boo boo boo m'était
tombée tu as fait tu as fait tu as fait
le guignol
tu as fait le guignol la partie d'avant
et là maintenant tu es moins le guignol
booba et c6
à
blum développer tranquille
alésia
tu vois je vois pas arriver dessus à 6
je suis tapis dans l'ombre de partout
ces cinq jeux des directs et pièces et
puis après je vais t'envoyer des pions
dessus ou page 5 vous match 4 ou match 3
non ça va attendre à échanger c'est pas
grave
l'oubli cavagnan f4 de commencer une
nuit tranquille
bref lui dit on se cache on se planque
pour le moment on va tu m du tour h5
dans la phase qui va dégager de partout
au bout la tour qui arriveront h5 ça
sert à rien mais ça te fait peur il
propose échange les dames c'est pas
chevaleresque jeu les tours qui sont
très bien placés et bien qu'à l'épreuve
trois échecs bouquet est proche trois
échecs je l'avais annoncé à l'afp quatre
sais pas quoi ça sert mais on est bien
on est chaud c'est un pion c'est de la
merde s'arrête c'est gagne petit ça à
tonton
mince mince mince ah non c'est nul ça
non on ce matin 8 c'est bien joué de sa
part n'aurait jamais dû perdre cette
partie on est complètement nul
enfin quand je te marche dessus avec ce
coup on va faire c'était beaucoup trop
conceptuel qui pouvait rien c'est trop
dessus toi me font des cinq caravanes et
y arrivant j'ai six les casses faible
comment je me balade
comment je me balade sur cet échiquier
la conception stratégique de malade il
n'a rien vu venir
les casses faible baude vinik serait
fier tout y est passé tous les concepts
stratégiques qui sont passés casse
faible affaiblissement sacrifices pour
l'activité tout était là on replace la
dame ou je te prends ton cul rond où je
ne défends
ces deux-là trop de stratégie ni c'est
faux quand même les excuses et à ce
niveau de jeu on est beaucoup trop de
tout âge et cater fourrage 3 je te cloud
à main cette dame prof de maths
ohlala quelle horreur
j'ai oublié d'un prof de maths euros il
n'a pas vu il a pas vus il l'a pas vu il
n'en peut plus il y aura des maths en 1
et la regarde le mat en deux qui est pas
rater ici boum c'est le beau jeu t'as
pas vu en maths en daim ou g5 direct ça
m'a trop excité le matin tu as raté vous
tarde à terme attendant c'est la honte
c'est la honte qui tombe sur toi ton peu
plus
5 regarde-moi sa place même pièce ça
c'est des vrais échecs regarde
l'activité
c'était des pièges de partout où la
perte de fouet dont g8 déplacement à 5
c'est pas parce qu'il ya plus d'âme sur
l'échiquier qu'on va pas les tomates et
tonton 3 je t'attaque à main c'est arte
et des cats c'est un peu chiant c'est
pas grave on pousse quand même environ
des cinq fonds de court ballet gratte et
onction à deux noms on peut pas tout lui
tu te coûte partout où tu es cloud est
un peu plus fous les trois regarde je
rentre de partout et ça tout est protégé
par le fouillis m de l'échiquier
mais qu'elles sont trop dessus
détiennent un peu plus je vais te
sacrifier la qualité dans la gueule en
trois c'est horrible blum le sacrifice
de qualité tant peu plus
ces concepts qui sont beaux trous
beaucoup trop compliqué c'est de la
stratégie de haut vol
c'est sa crise de qualité positionnelle
c'est beaucoup trop dessus je prenne
vraiment vous expliquer si vous voulez
cf
c'est trop dessus ces sacrifices la
c'est ça ça requiert un voilà il ya un
prérequis quand même qu'ils étaient trop
importants je suis vraiment désolé
j'aimerais bien pouvoir vous expliquer
ce tri pédagogique après très
pédagogique
mais bon c c voilà faut être séduit au
vol de pédagogie on ne peut pas t'aider
gens ont essayé d'expliquer mais n'ont
jamais réussi beaucoup trop compliqué
voilà c'est sera crise du sacrifice ou
jay 4 bouger 5vous m'acheter adoum h5
beau match 6 des quatre bunkers français
5 20 min vous mais ça peut quand même
ces quatre jeux partout boom trois là je
me développe car il y est roi
paris les dépecer là il n'en peut plus
il a plu à ses pièces sur l'échiquier il
n'en peut plus il a ramassé des pions
mais maintenant il se rend compte de son
erreur
les pions ça ne sert à rien c'est de la
merde
combien de fois il va faire vous
expliquer ne mangez jamais pions quand
il est depuis en prison ne prenez pas ça
ne sert à rien perdre de temps perdait
du temps
on attend d'une fois damages 5 pour groc
pougues roquettes ont peu plus aux
poubelles 4 commente objet de ramasser
des pions c'est des miettes de pain que
je t'envoie attend peu plus il n'en peux
plus je te prends et tout ça pour gagner
quoi
tous ces efforts pour gagner quoi une
qualité tu es malade tonton tout ça pour
une calloc'h c'est de la folie tonton
pour qu'une calloc'h c'est de la folie
ce que tu as fait c'est de la folie pure
à
tu ne peux pas te permettre pour une
calloc'h les regarde regarde ton ce que
je fais ou boum boum des gages pour une
cloche pour une call of
qu'est-ce que tu es venu me faire vous
mâche 5 est ce que tu es venu me faire
ton ton ces petits joueurs
allez viens chez catherine et théâtraux
prochain à tonton voilà tu obligé de
donner un pion comme ça je te le dis
pour une calèche n'avez pas le droit de
faire ça tout pouvait pas à main ceux ci
c'est mauvais ça va mettre le foin f5
d'abord allez-vous cavale et a5 et b3 ya
trop de trous qui ces quatre îles et
route par tous et du gruyère poursuites
vous la double attaque d'objets devenus
tadam
amincie m il ya tout qui tombe
heureusement qu'il n'a pas pris mon
série fait tour c'est un sinon j'étais
très mal
petit rock comment je te marche dessus
avec ce coup commencé de l'humiliation
d'avoir roke est un peu plus
il va essayer de ramener ces y vas y vas
y vas essayer de ramener du matériel de
ce côté là attention te faire [ __ ] en
c2 et le fou qui revient à angers 6 bout
enfin ça c'est un peu embêtant est ce
que c'est le beau jeu de faire nul
tonton
paris fait nul non et c'est le beau jeu
allez on prend le risque ont fait de
beaux jeux aussi
on a là ce matin quand même un tonton et
ben voilà le beau jeu et ben voilà le
beau jeu où j'ai 4 h 4 h 5 g 5 c'est pas
grave on appris de l'espace que le
concept de l'espace aux échecs
à
bon cavalier à 6 tours ch défend tout
d'un bébé 3 je défends tous
faire fou ici seulement fermer mes
pièces non 3d 2 c'est le concept a3 on
va dégager des pièces quatre attaques
tous partout tout le temps ça c'est des
vrais échecs fait quand même plaisir
avec cette personne c'est qu'on aura pu
lui faire comprendre le concept des
vrais échecs on sent la métamorphose
on sent la métamorphose chez lui
on a fait une bonne action ah mince et
la tour derrière
sans ce qu'il a compris ce que c'était
les vrais échecs ça ça fait plaisir
à
alors elle se concentre un peu boum boum
boum boum boum boum boum
boum boum boum boum boum livré échec
ah le pauvre c'est mal pour lui
franchement
sérieux je suis triste pour lui soucier
des pions doublé mais comment ça sert à
rien les pions doublé tant de choses à
rattraper dans les écoles d'échecs
c'est une horreur il pense que les pions
doublé c'est important mais où on
emmenait quoi comment est on tombé si
bas
ça se fait reprendre de parts comme
c'est une horreur
ce pas grâce le faire un échec en huit
heureux
je m'attends g2 qui arrive chauffe
marcel chaud et en français ça a été un
peu chiant
sacrifice de dames positionne elle se
prend vraiment tous les fondamentaux des
échecs 1
je prends tous les fondamentaux du boom
chez aesc
donc à la volée avec le roi aurait
peut-être un peu abusé sur salat sa
fille suzanne c'est peut-être un peu
trop mais sous les fondamentaux du bund
chaise
on a fait beaucoup trop de nouveautés
théorie pour lui beaucoup trop en avance
sur la théorie on peut plus je pense la
prochaine fois mains sales qui ont dit
on mais bon sinon l'esprit parce
prochaine fois qu'on fasse 15 -
nouveauté théorique
non quand même c'est beaucoup mais
peut-être un peu un peu trop loin
elle est un peu trop loin dans les
concepts la finale
à
cet amoureux en maths on a les trois ans
et qu'on s'installe et on en fait on en
fait une dernière allait dernière je
commence à fatiguer les banquiers pour
la dernière je pense qu'il faut qu'on y
aille à fond je pense vraiment qu'il
faut qu'on voit là qu'on fasse le
florilège pas un florilège on s'en fout
de tout les cif f3 ouais on lui donne
des pièces on s'en fout bout on prend
une pièce en bref si c'est de la merde
les cavaliers merde et on paiera fou
aussi c'est de la merde on perd la tour
là-bas on fait on est on tente un
florilège
on tente un florilège un échec boum
quand même rien du tout la has et à la
tour qui t'ont blum ta tour c'est de la
merde tente le florilège
ok c'est de la merde
c'est chaud là florilège
dégage dégage avec ta pièce
voilà on est complètement foutu on aura
raté le florilège
trop solide
un peu plus arnaquer y'avait attend 17
bon ok on va arrêter là
on va arrêter là mais c'était pas mal ce
n'est pas mal c'est pas mal le deuxième
on a réussi à le tenir le premier le
premier c'était chaud j'aurais dufermont
à n'importe quoi du coup la question
qu'est ce que vous en avez pensé parce
que ça vous a plu est ce que ça vous a
pas plu
est-ce que vous avez tant payless ou pas
toujours notre avis et maintenant on
n'est pas sûr sur la chaîne officielle
de chess comme je peux pourquoi
donc les gens bien aimé
je suis bien fatigué là les gens je vais
même détruit
même puis nrj cauet c'est pourquoi c'est
pas sûr surtout chaise comme tvg pas je
ne crois pas
je suis ce que j'ai pu j'aurais aimé
faire plus de plus de beau jeu mais
j'aurais voulu faire plus de beau jeu
aux dommages contre le grand maître
qu'on ait perdu nous a bien dominé quand
même faut reconnaître il a fait le beau
jeu qu'ai je fait ce que j'ai pu 1
c'était pas c'est pas évident
hm était très fort et le jem été très
fort le jem était trop fort en fait
moquer l'été 2007 40 sur sur une chaise
comme c'est hyper fort en bullet et du
coup il était un peu trop fort mais bon
j'aurais bien peu changé de style plutôt
en fait
du coup les gens il est tant de temps je
passe à tous les jours que le jeudi il
sera temps de partir
on n'aura pas réussi à mettre en pls mai
mais bon le deuxième on aura plus ou
moins réussis quand même du coup c'est
pas mal quand je vous souhaite à tous
une bonne soirée et à bientôt ciao ciao